[Musique]
celle qui dans le gouvernement 15,9 est
toujours là ministre des famille de
l'enfance et des droits de la femme est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
le bonsoir mesdames rossignol bonsoir
madame la ministre des familles donc
merci d'être avec nous vous allez
répondre et à trois grandes questions au
cours de cette émission
soutenez-vous la candidature de manuel
valls vous le dirai dans un instant à
jean francis pécresse
croyez vous que les français épargnent
auront à nouveau 21 avril à la gauche à
la gauche divisée comme jamais là vous
le dirai à lui si le malandain de la sp
enfin pour évoquer vos combats notamment
celui qui vous attend demain au sénat
questions sur les délits d' entrave ali
vgs que en fait vous voulez créer une
nouvelle menace pour la liberté
d'expression c'est ce que disent vos
détracteurs vous eh bien vous voulez
vous en prendre aux sites internet et
notamment au numéro vert qui cherchait
dissuader les femmes de pratiquer un
avortement mais d'abord une question
d'actualité
[Musique]
seniors est ce que vous êtes heureuse
heureuse dans ma vie heureuse dans mon
rôle de ministre est reconduite
oui oui je suis heureuse parce que
j'aime c'est un portefeuille j'ai un
périmètre qui est un beau un beau
portefeuille ministériel c'est à dire
que s'occuper des enfants des familles
et des droits des femmes c'est s'occuper
de quasiment tout le monde et c'est des
vrais combats etc des vraies avancées
pour la société quand est ce que vous
l'avez su que vous étiez maintenant vous
à passer un petit coup de fil comment ça
se passe ah non on a un coup de fil en
général quand on est devenus maintenant
quand on est promu
quand on est appelé quand on est
débarqué ça m'est pas arrivé mais il
faut comprendre qu'on n'avait pas trop
souvent on l'apprend ltd dont j'ai
regardé la télévision ce matin comme
tout le monde et puis j'ai vu les deux
des trois annonces qui se sont succédé
qui remplaçait bernard cazeneuve et
changement mais la permutation donc pas
d'information officielle
wallach vraisemblablement y avait
peut-être pas se poser de questions elle
le choix qui est fait c'est
effectivement le choix de ramper ses
deux premiers ministres
avec la conséquence que ça sur le
ministère de l'intérieur est ce que vous
êtes heureuse désormais vous allez vous
répondre oui évidemment de travailler
avec bernard cazeneuve
oui mais je travaillais déjà avec d'un
art cazeneuve mais là c'est le chef oui
c'est sept chefs il à moi j'aime bien
comme disait le premier ministre
précédent
le chef est là pour chiffrer et bernard
cazeneuve a la capacité non pas d'être
autoritaire manuel valls était pas non
plus mais on lui prêtait quand même ça
bonchamp es là il n'était pas au rythme
avec les femmes n'ont pas autorité avec
ses ministres
d'abord il est soutenait il les défend
des quand il était attaqué ça c'est mon
révélé de nombreuses fois quand marisol
touraine par exemple été beaucoup
attaqué sur le tiers-payant il l'a
défendu quand on est ministre on attaque
et les défend des et le nouveau il
allait même capacité à être un chef
d'equipe c'est-à-dire à extraire de nous
le meilleur à nous faire bien travailler
ensemble et puis il a une expérience qui
remarqua moi j'ai travaillé déjà avec
lui et son ministère sur les questions
de prévention leur indique alisation et
d'accompagnement des familles des jeunes
qui sont partis en syrie accor est ce
que ce choix de bernard cazeneuve c'est
aussi celui du soulagement pour france ô
là on n'est pas pouvoir se reposer sur
lui
pendant les cinq mois qui viennent la
vie peut-être qu'il a pour se reposer
tout court assez fine il à la guerre au
sommet le bras de fer mais le
quinquennat a fêté le quinquennat d'un
bras de fer entre le premier ministre et
président de la république mais sauf que
hier à ces dernières semaines
est ce qu'on a vu sur la durée c'est une
très courte période
manuel valls est un premier ministre
extrêmement loyale et protecteur aussi à
l'égard du président de la république et
le schéma qu'avait manuel valls chaque
foyer a travaillé c'était de permettre à
françois hollande est de nouveau
candidat manuel valls n'avait vraiment
oui vraiment il n'y a pas d'arrière
pensée et donc jeu pour revenir à la
question vous aux aînés un instant oui
je pense que le choix du président la
république de nommer bernard cazeneuve
comme premier ministre je crois pas que
ces choix de se reposer je pense que
c'est un choix qui est celui d'à présent
la république qui est toujours d'abord
et avant tout préoccupés des questions
de sécurité
la menace terroriste n'a pas diminué
avec les événements politiques que nous
connaissons il n'y a pas de lien entre
les deux elle est toujours présente et
le président de la république est
totalement engagée sur ce sujet et on ne
m'en bernard cazeneuve le miz intérieur
respecté par les français sur les
questions de sécurité sur le rôle qu'il
a joué dans le service tous d'accord
c'est un impératif absolu pour le reste
c'est la fin de règne ce que non ce que
d'une présidence et je gouvernerai et je
protègerai les français jusqu'à la fin
du quinquennat
voilà il n'y a pas de vacance du pouvoir
aujourd'hui avec le choix de bernard
cazeneuve
c'est le choix de continuer de
travailler prioritairement sur la
prévention du terrorisme et la
protection d'accord parce que ça
malheureusement ça nous est imposée par
le contexte que l'on connaît mais pour
l'instant je vous le disais c'est quand
même la fin de règne écoutez la fin de
règne c'est une expression qui a une
connotation délétère on ne fait plus
rien pendant la fin de règne c'est pas
le cas je tous les ministres sont au
travail moi je suis engagé je ne propres
on en parlera tout à l'heure j'ai un
texte une proposition moi que je
soutiens qui vient au sénat demain j'ai
une campagne on en parlera prenantes la
leur aussi quand on le sait qu sexiste
mais globalement je suis engagé dans
diverses mesures sur l'égalité
j'ai des mesures dans le projet doit
donc pas se compromettre avec christian
jacob bernard cazeneuve n'est pas là
pour fermer les lumières
un nom bien marquer bernard cazeneuve et
là au contraire pour rassurer les
français et travailler donc là jours
très bien alors donc vous l'avez rappelé
à l'instant le rang social vous vous
restez en tous les cas en première ligne
sur plusieurs sujets qui par ailleurs
vous tiennent à coeur
on va en parler donc au cours de cette
émission mais d'abord on accueille jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique qui vient
vous poser une autre question politique
bonsoir michel concevoir le françois
rossignol alors depuis hier soir manuel
valls est donc candidat à la primaire du
ps de la gauche du ps
est ce que vous le soutiendrez ce que
vous voterez pour lui je vais voter pour
un manuel valls et je le soutiendrai
parce que dans cette primaire est
ensuite dans l'élection présidentielle
je n'imagine pas que le débat ait lieu
devant les français entre des candidats
à la prison de la république qui tous
soit en jambes soient piétine
ce quinquennat est le bilan que nous
portons et je crois que le bilan que
nous avons bien sûr il y à des
frustrations
bien sûr il y a des résultats qui ont
été longs à venir
et il ya aussi des succès et des choses
dont ceux très fier mais en particulier
dans mon secteur je pourrais vous parler
de mes sujet de fierté est donc bien
entendu il est indispensable que à mon
sens le candidat qui représentera le
parti socialiste et la gauche
plus largement dans cette élection
présidentielle soit aussi porteur du
bilan je crois que les français n'y
comprendraient rien s'il n'avait
personne pour représenter ce quinquennat
rainbow chat gouverner cinq ans et elle
ne peut pas être absente du débat
deux à la fois du bilan mais aussi du
projet donc si je vous comprends bien
vous votre et valser vous le soutiendrez
parce qu'il défendra bien le bilan de
françois hollande
je sais le sien au cices notre bilan
collectif et je bien sûr c'est un bilan
collectif le bilan de françois hollande
c'est le bilan d'une majorité
parlementaire également c'est un bilan
que nous portons tous et c'est un bilan
qui a suffisamment d'avancé sur le plan
social je peux en parler si vous voulez
de ce qu'on a fait en matière d'accès à
la retraite des carrières longues de
protection sociale nous avons consolidé
bien sûr matière d'éducation le bilan en
matière de politique familiale en
matière d'égalité femmes hommes en
matière de justice en matière de
transparence
tous ces éléments du bilan ils ont
vocation à être présents parce qu'ils
ont vocation est défendue pas simplement
pour défendre votre bilan mais pour
défendre ce qui ce que ce bilan incarne
pour les français s'il est tellement bon
ce bilan pourquoi au fond françois
hollande unis n'est pas allé même je ne
vous dis pas que ce bilan est tellement
bon je ne vous dis pas ça
non et et à défendre mes idées de l'état
lui-même n'y aille pas parce que le chef
parce que le président de la république
a constaté qu'il y avait donc d'abord il
a été victime pendant depuis 2012 d'une
fixation d'une crispation et d'une de
tak tak sur sa personne qui ont commencé
très rapidement il ya probablement
toujours dans la vème république une
dimension personnelle et une dimension
collective et dans la dimension
personnelle le président de la
république a évalué et d'ailleurs il l'a
dit dans le discours qu'il a prononcé
quand il annonce aux français qu'il ne
se représenterait pas que dans l'intérêt
de de nous tous ils avaient décidé de
renoncer à se présenter parce qu'il a
peut-être fait lui aussi des erreurs ou
des fautes est ce que ce livre de
confidences à n'a pas été bon pour vous
en particulier une sorte de goutte d'eau
qui a fait déborder le vase et qui a
fait qu'à un moment donné vous avez fait
le choix du candidat valls plutôt du
candidat hollande foot et je pense qu'il
serait malvenu désagréments inutilement
désagréable et que ça relèverait de
l'acharnement
maintenant que françois hollande ait des
idées une palette de nouveaux candidats
de continuer à discuter par de la même
façon dans nos discussions
il ya trois semaines ou un mois sur sa
place dans le bilan du quinquennat
même sur l'ism ce livre sur des éléments
qui ont effectivement abandonné plus
obturer la perception collective du
bilan est-ce que la candidature de
manuel valls peut être une règle une
candidature de réconciliation comme il
l'a dit hier soir et ce qu'il vous
paraît être à l'épicentre du ps c'est
une bonne question c'est qu'est ce qui
est intéressant d'observer aujourd'hui
sur cette question de l'épicentre est
venu le mot clé du débat politique
depuis quelques temps où le coeur du ps
en voilà mais non mais c'est le mot est
puissante et juste
d'abord coin une remarque tu rentres
fillon est l'épicentre de la droite
c'est à dire que c'est un candidat la
droite que je qualifierais de dur sur le
plan économique dure sur le plan social
et conservatrice sur le plan de 2h30
alors le mot moeurs sultan sociétal le
mot mort c'est une petite connotation à
l'ancienne vous avez 100 et 200 le plan
sociétal
pour autant il faut d'abord se garder
d'avoir un raisonnement en miroir
totalement mécanique qui consistera
pensé que puisque l'épicentre de la
droite est très à droite
l'épicentre de la gauche serait
forcément très à gauche
le problème que nous avons et c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons de la
diversité et les divisions aujourd'hui
dé gauche c'est que l'épicentre de la
gauche
on ne sait pas exactement où il est et
je ne crois pas qu'il soit ni une ni
d'un côté quelque part entre jean luc
mélenchon et philippe poutou ni de
l'autre côté quelque part entre emmanuel
macron et françois bayrou ce que
d'ailleurs c'est plus la gauche eric
emmanuel macron n'est pas très très loin
à la de deux personnes que vous venez de
citer deux français de macron je pensais
à lui non mais je sais ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est ce que je veux
simplement dire que c'est un des sujets
sait où est l'épicentre de la gauche et
le défi de la courbe des taux et manuel
valls
c'est justement de construire
l'épicentre c'est qu'on veut donner à la
gauche
le ce point qui n'est pas un point de
compromis mais qui est un point en
construction les quais parce que des
questions n'ont pas été will régler mais
manuel valls est quand même l'homme de
la loi travail par exemple c'est celui
qui a été pour la déchéance est ce que
c'est parce que là dans cette gauche là
vous vous reconnaissez ce que c'est dans
ce ps là vous vous reconnaissez est
devant nous c'est possible après ces
différentes fractures au sein de
l'appareil fin au sein de votre parti
d'eau réconcilier ce que lui-même appelé
hier de deux gauches irréconciliables
et maintenant manuel valls apporter
toutes les réformes de du canada du
quinquina de manière très solidaire et
extrêmement protectrice à l'égard du
président la république sur la déchéance
de nationalité
je ne sais pas jusqu'à quand il a été
favorable j'avais cru comprendre que
tout le monde devait douter quand même
assez vite de la pertinence et le
président de la république d'ailleurs là
encore ce peut être pas utile d'y
revenir a dit que c'était un cd sont
regrette dans ce quinquennat la
déchéance de nationalité
et la loi travail elle a été portée par
le premier ministre est aussi le
président de la république nous l'avons
collecte a été porté collectivement je
pense que manuel valls a beaucoup agi
pour protéger président de la république
pendant ce quinquennat c'est à dire que
il a joué le rôle de premier ministre à
dire que premier ministre et celui qui
va en avant qui prend les coups le
souvent également et qui portent et
aujourd'hui manuel valls il est en
situation de construire justement ce
nouvel épicentre alors à pourvoir il
avait rentré juste une chose aujourd'hui
est ce que manuel valls est aujourd'hui
à l'épicentre de la gauche je ne sais
pas et nous n'avons rien pour le dire
est ce que manuel valls peut engager une
dynamique qui lui permettent à la fin de
la primaire d'avoir de la gauche ce soir
rassembler de nouveau autour d'un axe
fort
oui je le crois alors c'est mal partis
quand même jour pour vous tout de suite
d'écoutés wheeler entre zones urbaines
oui à écouter les premières réactions et
hier soir dans la foulée de sa
candidature à gauche c'est une levée de
boucliers quelle que soit la sincérité
des intentions du candidat manuel valls
ses intentions de candidats contredisent
ces actes de premier ministre et je
pense que sa candidature est sans doute
la plus clivante qu'ils soient
aujourd'hui au parti socialiste a raison
des choix qu'il a fait très présente
dans ce tir un candidat qui représente
le coeur des valeurs du parti socialiste
c'est pas évident manuel valls candidat
a prononcé un discours d'opposant à sa
propre politique
il est maintenant le premier défenseur
de l'unité de la gauche alors qu'il a
théorisé les gauches irréconciliables
quel est donc le manuel valls qui s'est
exprimé ce soir
celui qui gouverne ou celui qui
candidatent le figaro ce matin rien
surprenant si ce n'est dans son pour son
éditorial manuel valls contre val ce
manuel est ce que vous êtes et ce que
vous reconnaissez quand même une forme
de contradiction entre son discours
d'hier soir et ce qu'il tenait comme
discours quand il était premier ministre
mais sans espoir on a bien vu le chemin
qu'il avait voulu tracer hier
dis je je trouvais reposer un chemin
c'est quoi ce jeu je trouve que le
discours d'hier soir c'est un discours
de candidat
ce n'est plus simplement les scores de
premier ministre mais dit deux choses
idées pour aider d'abord qu'il portera
le bihan et c'est important j'ai évoqué
il ya déjà un instant qu'il portera le
bilan est que il le met dans son ce
chemin tout ce qui a été en même temps
sont une partie de son identité
c'est à dire la laïcité l'égalité la
fraternité et ils se situent ils se
situent dans une candidature
républicaine républicaine et sociale
c'est ça la c'est ça le chemin de la
candidature de manuel valls aujourd'hui
alors j'entends bien ce que disent les
autres candidats à la primaire va tout
le monde dit ça en républicaine et
sociale sais pas mais c'est d'abord la
question de la laïcité on en parlera
tout à l'heure j'imagine quand on parle
du vg
mais la question de républicaine il
suffit pas de le dire encore faut-il le
prouver mais surtout encore faudrait un
programme qui soit adaptée ça quand
françois fillon nous dit qu'à la fois il
veut réserver la sécurité sociale aux
gens qui sont atteints d'affections de
longue durée ou qu'il veut supprimer
cinq cent mille fonctionnaires
c'est peut-être ils peuvent toujours
dire qu'il est républicain une fois
qu'elle ait dit ça mais c'est la
première fois depuis que je joue observe
la politique de prêt ça fait quand même
quelques années que je vois un candidat
qui est aussi franchement nettement en
rupture avec ce qui constitue l'histoire
collective et entre autres et en
particulier programme du conseil de la
résistance c'est la première fois que je
vois un candidat qui dit voilà je veux
en finir avec la sécurité sociale en
france parce que ce qu'a dit françois
fillon c'est jose on en finit aka
sécurité sociale c'est un tout petit peu
résumé quand même non à écouter quand on
commence à dire j'aurais attendu chez
vraiment quand on commencerait millions
de chercheurs jeu quand on commence à
dire que la sécurité sociale sera
réservé à ceux qui sont atteints de
longue maladie à ceux qui ont des
maladies lourdes et que pour tout le
reste ce sera renvoyé vers les
assurances privées ou les mutuelles sans
d'ailleurs nous préciser ces gîtes des
mutuelles du code de la mutualité où des
mutuelles du code des assurances
là on est dans une véritable de rupture
sur le principe même de la sécurité
sociale c'est à dire
la solidarité sur la prise en charge
globale de la maladie et surtout cette
idée qui sous-tendait l'assurance
maladie qui est que c'est en soignant
tous les jours des petites maladies
qu'on a qu'on se prémunissant contre les
graves mais y aura des modifications
sans doute là dessus puisque bernard
accoyer aujourd'hui même à un grand
soutien françois fillon dit qu'il faut
apporter des éclaircissements et lui est
opposée ce qui est annoncé en matière d
étatisation de la sécu a donc lendemain
les courbes évoluer le projet aussi de
ce côté là ce serait bien que françois
fillon n'est pas un discours qu'on gagne
et les maires de la droite un autre
discours ensuite avec des gens qui le
soutiennent parce que lui aussi si
l'alternance se produisait si gagner
l'élection présidentielle aurait quand
même une majorité qui peut être accru à
ce qu'il a dit pendant la primaire
d'autant plus que je pense que ce qu'il
a dit pendant la primaire correspond
exactement à ce qu'ils pensent dernière
celle sur qui nie par exemple alors sur
le bio fini vous vous étiez plutôt en
phase avec la position de manuel valls
cet été mais pour des raisons qui sont
pas exactement les mêmes lui était
content enfin pour l'interdiction
municipale indé du port du burkini mais
pour des raisons de laïcité vous plutôt
par défense de la baie de la féminité
enfin de l'homme et de l'égalité femmes
l'égalité mais c'était tout d'abord je
crois que les questions de laïcité sont
pas dissociables détection d'égalité
femmes hommes parce que la laïcité c'est
ce qui a permis aux femmes de
s'émanciper des interdits religieux qui
ont tous leur religion traditionnelle
pour vocation le contrôle du corps des
femmes et de la sexualité est pour moi
effectivement la laïcité c'est l'outil
c'est un des outils de l'égalité femmes
hommes je crois pas que manuel valls est
une approche différente et qu' il ait
une approche abstraite de la laïcité est
d'ailleurs souvent ils l'aident il a dit
avec des formules parfois image et sur
le lien entre laïcité et émancipation et
libertés des femmes
après la question de la terre la
question de l'interdiction j'ai toujours
dit qu'en fait je pensais que s'adresse
ce n'est pas le sujet le sujet et de
dénommer quel était le sens et de se
dire que pour que les fans que c'était
plutôt sale sujet et de resituer
toujours la question en termes de
liberté
aller et venir et libertés des femmes
toutes dernières questions mais je pense
que votre réponse sera brève imaginons
que le 29 janvier manuel valls ne gagne
pas cette élection primaire est ce que
vous vous engagez à soutenir le
vainqueur quel qu'il soit mais c'est le
l'exercice même de la primaire qui veut
ça c'est que bien sûr la réponse est oui
et c'est une c'est une évidence pour moi
que la primaire désignera un candidat
qui sera le candidat de ceux qui ont
voté à la primaire
mais vous savez que si stéphane le faut
je n'irai pas cultiver mon jardin pour
être encore plus clair ce n'est pas
manuel valls qui vous savez que si
stéphane le foll avait été nommé à
matignon un peu vous ne seriez plus be
nice
peut-être parce qu'ils voulaient des
sanctions c'est ce qu'il a dit lors d'un
déjeuner quel rapport existe un aurait
des sanctions contre une valve système
et quelques pensez vous de cette
démarche priori ans car je pense que
stéphane le foll accompagnent françois
hollande depuis des années depuis dédits
très longtemps que c'est le le compagnon
de tout temps de françois hollande et
que le renoncement de france vraiment de
la semaine dernière a été extrêmement
douloureuses sur le plan affectif pour
ses proches et que quand on souffre des
fois on dit des choses qui dépassent sa
pensée
d'accord vous avez une pensée
particulière pour votre ami valls east
j'imagine jeanmairet le wang a été un
peu relégués dans le gouvernement la rb6
pour gradés il est rétrogradé était
secrétaire d'état aux secrétaires d'état
moi stratégique pour lui aujourd'hui ce
qu'ils disent qu'il va faire même si
c'est très important le développement on
est d'accord la francophonie vous avez
une course à part pour lui nous coûter
je pense pas qu'il soit malheureux mais
voilà je sais qu'il n'est pas malheureux
de ses nouvelles responsabilités que
saint julien saubade à l'état la
francophonie comme un jeu très important
effectué remercie beaucoup d'entre 6
lucile malandain de l' effet arrive
désormais pour la deuxième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité
l'épreuve de vérité avec l'afp
bonsoir lucide mont-saint-michel son
sommet d'avant signol alors croyez vous
dans la situation actuelle tels que ça
se présente pour la présidentielle 2017
que les français aient devons épargner
un nouveau 21 avril à la gauche et au
prij évidemment qui a volé ma réponse a
dit lisez comme divisée comme comme
jamais même de ne presque encore plus
divisé qu'en 2002 vous pourrez dire si
on compte le nombre de candidats qui se
présentent à la terre de la primaire et
or de la primaire voilà on est la
différence avec 2002 c'était en 2002 il
y avait pas de primaire
on est dans un processus différentes
2002 et puis ces produits 2002 qu'elle
essaie quand même à la fois des
blessures et des souvenirs à ceux qui y
ont participé
ou qu'ils ont vécu aujourd'hui nous
avons une primaire la primaire elle a
aussi pour vocation si nous le
réussissons cette primaire de permettre
à la gauche de construire un
rassemblement et je suis comme michel
grossiord je pense que ce serait bien
que les français épargnent pas
simplement à la gauche mais s'épargne un
même et par nos pays un nouveau 21-avril
surtout qu' il n'est pas dit que ce set
nous ce nouveau côté avril soit le même
en avril d'un certain point de vue ça
commence mal et ça finit bien
j'ose dire le deuxième tour le premier
tour est le premier tour et est
désormais le deuxième tour se finit par
la victoire de jacques chirac à laquelle
j'aime aussi contre la plus 80% de la
bulle 80 % des voix euh là les risques
sont différents
françois fillon n'est pas jacques chirac
d'eni dans son programme ni dans son
identité dans la partie de la droite
avec elle ils se rattachent nina la
droite qui le porte et m'a écouté là on
a beaucoup de diaboliser dans le passé
jacques chirac tu sais ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui avec françois fillon
n'ont écouté jacques chirac a toujours
eu ce nom je crois que c'est pas deux
personnalités identique
j'ai pas souvenir qu'on est moi je me
souviens de quelques petites phrases de
jacques chirac
souvenez vous il y avait fait chevaucher
jeu c'est une petite phrase de jacques
chirac mais en en
en 2002 on met dans une suisse on
connaît déjà
on a vu chirac déjà présente la
république
on sait que jacques chirac est somme
toute dans une espèce de deux traditions
d'une droite qui continue de s'inspirer
du compromis gaulliste voilà pour la
fusion c'est différent parce que s'ils
s'obstinent à faire la campagne qu'il a
fait dans l'imprimé à dire ce qu'il dit
en particulier en termes de modèle
social s'ils s'obstinent à vouloir que
margaret thatcher de la france un
certain point de vue et à être aussi le
conservateur parmi les conservateurs
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils créent les
conditions pour que le deuxième tour en
2017 soit aussi facile que l'a été celui
de jacques chirac mais elle avoue
qu'elle aurait dû principe déjà que la
gauche et élimine notre approche
continue on est dans l'hypothèse où
c'est la gauche qui est devant qui est
face à marine le pen au deuxième tour
je ne suis pas sûr non plus que le
discours de la droite d'aujourd'hui
favorise le rassemblement républicain au
deuxième tour contre marine le pen
donc je ne vois qu'une solution pour
nous prémunir de marine le pen en 2017
c'est un deuxième tour droite gauche
mais voilà celui là et qui d'ailleurs
ressemble bien plus et correspond bien
davantage au pays qu'un autre type de
deuxième tour dans lequel le front
national serait présent mais alors on
voit déjà dans les sondages les premiers
sondages qui sont sortis depuis le
retrait de françois hollande que manuel
valls pour l'instant est placé à la
cinquième place qu'il arrive derrière
emmanuel macron et derrière jean-luc
mélenchon qui aucun des deux n'a accepté
de participer à la primaire et ils ont
redit l'a à nouveau que il ne
participerait pas à la primaire oui mais
alors quel espace politique dont com
quels moyens de trouver sa place entre
ces deux d'abord on va peut-être on va
peut-être déjà commencé par prendre un
peu de distance par rapport à ces fameux
sondages qui ont été faits quand
effectivement déjà les deux candidats
que vous citez le sont depuis un moment
alors que la gauche gouvernementale
n'avait pas de candidat désigné
voilà donc on ne savait pas qui était
dans les centres non j'en attends pas
d'effets vice dans les sondages
j'attends dans la primaire un débat à
gauche une dynamique à gauche qui fasse
que cette primaire permettent de
construire
une opposition à la droite sur une
position de deuxième tour voilà ce que
j'attends de la primaire et la primaire
elle se elle sera ce que les français en
feront un certain point de vue si nous
avons une primaire qui est large qui est
dit kéké qui intéresse procès que l'élan
pourrait emporter les bons scores de
emmanuel macron par exemple oui bien sûr
pourrait affadir et maintenant qu'on
vous pensez vraiment quelle mauvaise
politique je pense qu'un espace
politique
je pense que aussi bien emmanuel macron
que jean luc mélenchon de manière
totalement différente ont prospéré dans
les sondages parce qu'ils étaient déjà
candidats qu'ils étaient les seuls
candidats que nous étions nous pour
notre part dans le flou et l'incertitude
sur notre candidat et que nous avons une
période on ne s'entraîne pas dans
laquelle il ya eu la primeur de la
droite qui a beaucoup pris beaucoup d
espace politique etc intéresser les
français
et puis il ya eu les deux des clés les
deux candidatures la gauche
gouvernementale entre maintenant dans sa
primaire donc c'est pour nous c'est
maintenant que tout commence pas
gouverner si mal si c'est arnaud
montebourg qui emporte la primaire ce
sera à vous pensé quand même la gauche
gouvernementale pour vous à bien ce sera
il leur ville mal il fait sa campagne
contre le milan essentiellement oui
bilan dont il est quand même aussi
comptable arnaud montebourg elle a été
ministre mais oui il est ministre et
l'aï là il a contribué à la désignation
de françois hollande en 2011 alors que
il y avait quelque chose d'un peu contre
intuitif au fait qu arnaud montebourg
choisissent de porter ces voix sur
françois hollande ça n'a pas peur ça n'a
pas aidé à clarifier d'ailleurs pour le
programme de 2012 puisque après on est
passé directement dans une campagne
présidentielle qui s'était faite autour
d'un choix
comment dire pragmatique on voit là pour
arnaud montebourg il a été candidat il a
été ministre jusqu'en 2014
areva 20 septembre 2014 et il est aussi
porteur de la première partie du
quinquennat
or ce quinquennat n'a pas une période où
on fait une politique formidablement de
gauche qui correspondrait à celle que
voulait à renouer une bourre et les
autres c'est tout voilà la politique de
l'offre recommencement suite et si je me
souviens bien
ce sont les élus
aux municipales de 2014 qui conduisent
au remaniement et arnaud montebourg est
aussi comptable des élections
municipales de 2014
donc ça sert à rien de vouloir se mettre
à distance de ce bilan et les deux dents
lui aussi voilà qui est dit alors en
tous les cas vous misez sur la dynamique
de la primaire 1 laurence rossignol
écouter ce que dit vous ne serez pas sûr
que peut-être passé pour le sénateur
républicain
roger karoutchi pour les lui pour la
gauche c'est fini lyon l'écoutent ya
rien à attendre les résultats sont
calamiteux je ne vois pas quel candidat
de gauche aujourd'hui peut dépasser 20%
ou alors il faut le cannet qui se retire
mais c'est pas c'est pas l'air du temps
et quand vous êtes dans l'échec la
spirale de l'échec est terrible parce
que personne ne veut se retirer parce
que personne ne veut dire que le bilan
est le sien parce que personne ne veut
dire que l'autre est meilleur à partir
de là la division fera les chèques et
les chèques faits la division c'est pas
un commentateur de la vie politique
c'est pas un politologue
c'est un sénateur les républicains qui
est acharnée à ce que d'une part son
camp gagne c'est bien normal mais
ensuite qu'est ce que la gauche
disparaissent parce que le sujet
pour les républicains c'est pas
simplement de gagner c'est après d'avoir
les mains libres pour mener leur
politique au riz savent que leur
politique n'est pas la politique que
veulent les français et c'est pas parce
que la droite veut la politique avec a
proposé françois fillon dans la primaire
que cette politique là pour reprendre la
fameuse le fameux épicentre si françois
fillon était l'épicentre de la droite il
n'est pas pour autant l'épicentre du
pays est en tous les cas pas sur le plan
social il y avait ces deux cellules à
bien appliquer sa politique pour
l'instant d'avoir relativement vie de
vomissements vous riez pas faire de la
politique autrement qu'avec les sondes a
lancé vrai on va passer notre temps à
commenter les sondages parce que les
sondages aussi créer un effet politique
mais s'est dit qu'on allait devenir les
pays ne veut pas tellement alors qu'il
ya plus de 4 millions de personnes
un jour veut se débarrasser de la gauche
quoi parce que des marchés ce qu'une
partie de la gauche ne veut pas se
débarrasser du parti socialiste aussi
est ce que ces deux questions alors si
tu veux vraiment bien sûr alors est ce
que bon alors on veut se débarrasser de
la gauche parce que la droite c'est
qu'il suffit pas d'avoir le pouvoir pour
mettre en oeuvre ses réformes et réussir
d'ailleurs on a des expériences et à
droite et à gauche qui prouve que c'est
plus compliqué que ça et que il faut
après à affronter le pays
et comme je voulais dis moi j'ai pas de
sondages j'ai ma connaissance du tir et
non du pays du territoire du mien qui me
fait dire que non les français ne sont
pas pour la suppression de 500 mille
fonctionnaires non les français ne sont
pas d'accord pour qu'on coup pour coup
non wimille tiendra bon bilan il verra
quand quand il expliquera dans une
petite commune que lorsque l'enseignant
comme l'instituteur part en retraite et
qu'il n'est pas remplacé parce que ça
fait pas ça rentre pas dans sa
comptabilité des fonctionnaires etc les
élèves sont dispatchés dans les autres
classes
je donne pas longtemps à françois fillon
pour que les rentrées scolaires soit d
incandescence et vous noterez quand même
que de ses rentrées scolaires
incandescente qu'on a connus ou en tant
qu'élu local je peux vous dire j'en ai
vu des rentrées scolaires avec les
parents contre les suppressions de
classes un village de l'oise oui dans
les villages de l'oise et puis et puis
pas que dans l'oise vient de partout
mais où depuis deux ans c'est quelque
chose qui a quasiment disparu parce que
nous avons enfin autant m le délai
nécessaire
donc je pense que françois fillon sait
très bien que il faut qu'il ait une
défaite politique et une défaite
sociologique sociales de la gauche
c'est exactement quand on dit que c'est
thatcher son modèle social son modèle
c'est vrai et thatcher ça a été la
défaite politique des travaillistes
suivi par la défaite sociale de la
classe ouvrière britannique est
aujourd'hui je conseille simplement à
tout le monde si on veut savoir sur le
plutôt que de regarder les sondages
achetons tous est prêt les oeuvres
complètes de ken loach et on saura ce
qui peut être attend la france et sa
guise et la national black la gauche ça
paraît relativement logique
je reviens sur mad men ma question qui
venait après était pas une partie de la
gauche qui voudra bien battre le ps sans
doute d'avoir le détruire sans doute
mais dans quel but
c'est comme ça qui est intéressant parce
que en fait cette gauche là elle ne
concourt dans la présidentielle que pour
être premier col est en fait mais il n'y
a pas de désistement on a dépeint jean
luc mélenchon se voit bien au deuxième
tour
oui il le dit à ses fans oui oui oui se
voit bien au deuxième tour je ne suis
pas quand je disais à tout à l'heure il
ne correspond pas non plus à l'épicentre
de la gauche
je le pense aussi jean luc mélenchon est
toujours confronté à un sujet et qui
pour moi est important c'est comment se
fait-il qu alors que depuis 2012
il n'a cessé de tailler en pièces la
politique du gouvernement ont dans
toutes les élections qui ont lieu
jusqu'à présent et ses pas et sondages
c'est les élections le front national
apparaît toujours quand même meilleur
instrument un meilleur outil que jean
luc mélenchon pour les déçus des
politiques des gouvernements successifs
cette question là il est possible de
poser aussi jean luc mélenchon pour le
moment dans les élections le front
national et est un meilleur au cours
pour les graisses populaire par exemple
moi je suis venu en homme de la grande
région nord pas de calais picardie que
jean luc mélenchon
donc cette question laïque doit cela
pose aussi jean-luc et il ne peut pas
dire aujourd'hui que tout naturellement
il peut garantir à qui que ce soit
d'être le candidat du deuxième tour et
quant à un deuxième tour marine le pen
jean-luc mélenchon là encore peut-être
qu'on pourrait éviter de voir ce que ça
donne et casque est aussi deux autres
candidatures celle de sylvia pinel pour
le prg d'une part et celle de yannick
jadot pour eux élevés qui sont
considérés comme des petites
candidatures
est-ce que celle ci ne risque pas de
grignoter juste ce qu'il faudrait par
exemple à manuel valls ou au candidat
qui sortira de la primaire pour passer
le 2e toi écoute on va attendre de voir
une version et dans ce cas là jusqu'à
les messages non lus ne peut être
candidat jusqu'au bout j'ai pas
totalement compris la candidature de
sylvia pinel celle là me laissait un peu
perplexe je dois dire oui j'en cherche
sans cesse de gagner des cadeaux elle a
du sens un candidat écologique
écologistes pardon c'est un candidat
écologiste qui est porteur de nombreuses
choses moi je pense que bien dit que je
dois sa place avec nous voilà je peux
par ailleurs on voit les invités à
participer à la primaire
et alors quelqu'un a dit il a déjà fait
une primaire est maintenant en faire
deux mais je pense qu'il a sa place dans
un rassemblement parce que la question
de la transition écologique
la question de la rupture pour la gauche
avec le productivisme est une question
importante
moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour ses
idées et je crois qu on a déjà fait des
choses ensemble on fait des choses
ensemble encore dans les rues étaient
enfermés pendant fasse encore merci
laisser troisième partie de l'épreuve de
vérité maintenant avec mais qu'est la
messe de public sénat qui arrive on va
évoquer laurence rossignol vos combats
comme ministre notamment des droits de
la femme
ministre des droits des femmes michel lo
giaco salarial avec le délit d'autres
avenues mais rien qui sera donc examinée
demain au sénat
portez-vous atteinte à la liberté
d'expression comme on l'entend depuis
une semaine peut-être on va reprendre
qu'est ce que le délit d' entrave tu
roulais sur les végétaux répondre à vos
questions
j'ai pas l'habitude de d'esquiver les
questions non mais pour nos spectateurs
sur aujourd'hui ce que nous observons
c'est qu' il n'existe des sites internet
extrêmement actifs qui sont en trois
lettres qui sont les outils de
propagande des associations anti ivg de
toutes celles et ceux qui n'ont jamais
renoncé dans leur hostilité à nouveau l
ivg et qui ont qui se sont installés sur
un créneau qui est celui de l'apparence
de la neutralité l'apparence de
l'information pour attirer des femmes
qui cherchent des informations santé
publique ou légal
par exemple je veux faire je peux
pratiquer une ivg quels sont les délais
quelles sont les techniques
à qui dois je m'adresser est-ce que
c'est remboursé le fait que georges
aussi une écoute psychologique parfois
des femmes qui cherchent une écoute
psychologique aussi parfois mais elle la
trouveront dans le parcours médical
il y a deux rendez-vous avec un médecin
et le médecin avec l'équipe médicale qui
va pratiquer les ivg va leur apporter
aussi cette écoute psychologique elle
est déjà là les coûts de psychologique
et est donc ces femmes sont attirées sur
ces sites elles pensent qu'elles
viennent d'entrer sur un site
d'information elle se retrouve au
téléphone avec des gens qui est des
écoutantes qui voudraient vous n auriez
pas forcément que sur internet on a
forcément de son téléphone numéro les
fameux numéro vert et vous si vous si
vous lisez un peu toutes les enquêtes
qui ont été faites à la fois par vos
collègues mais aussi par des
associations auprès de ses numéros verts
on y décline un tissu de ce qu'ils
sortent médicales scientifiques du style
ivg vous rend stérile toutes les femmes
qui ont fait n'ayant qu'un repos une
progression également assisté ont toutes
une ivg avant et tous vos enfants sont
traumatisés y compris ceux qui naîtrait
après divisé et au bout du compte il ya
ces cétacés que conversations
téléphoniques ont comme finalité de
faire douter la femme de sa décision et
de lui faire perdre
on pensait finir par dépasser les délais
donc c'est à ça que nous nous sommes
attaqués d'abord par la méthode du
référencement certes nous avons un sit
in est un site gouvernemental ivg point
gouv.fr qui donnent des informations
fiables objectives et de nature ne
totalement le dit aux français allez
voir ce site de référence
oui mais ça des passions retardé c'est
ce que vous dites non je dis ce site est
un site internet
mais en réalité quand une femme veut des
informations elle va taper enceinte a va
taper avortement est la table et elle a
un risque en fonction de la halle de
l'aléatoire et le référencement des
sites vous pouvez faire monter un site
dans le référencement
et puis il suffit que x mots-clés dit
qu'ils soient entrés sur la page où la
page du mode de nouveaux temps de
recherche voilà et le site officiel va
redescendre dire que quelque part vous
avez perdu cette bataille d'internet on
a perdu c'est vous aussi sur ce site
certainement entre l'information fiable
vérifiez sûr c'est que vous donnez et le
tissu de mensonges complotistes qui
circulent sur internet
vous avez peut-être aussi un peu perdu
la bataille mais vous êtes breton
n'avait pas cessé de l'amener et vous
avez pas renoncé et moi n'ont d'autre
mot et moi non plus je n'ai alors
annoncé la question parce que je ne sais
ce qui est insupportable dans cette
affaire c'est qu'elle part du présupposé
qu'une femme qui a des effets runes ivg
est une femme qui n'a pas réfléchi est
une femme qui a pris une décision légère
et qu'il faudrait la faire réfléchir
or quand une femme a décidé de faire une
ivg croyez moi qu'elle a réfléchi faire
par rapport à ce qu'on dont on parle
c'est la liberté d'expression parce que
je sais que vous allez me dire ça c'est
la droite qui dit sam il n'y a pas qu'à
droite on parlait de caroline associe
comme green a dit carline de haas qui
parle aussi de liberté d'expression on
entend aussi le conseil constitutionnel
qui pourrait dire que cette loi et par
l'importante quantité saisie parce qu'il
ya aussi ce problème de liberté
d'expression même sur la légalité des
délits que l'outil est le bon qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez écouter demain je viens
au sénat bonjour efforts à faire les
avons marre et du sérieux dans sa
désormais doigts si nous sommes d'accord
entre gens de bonne volonté
pour constater que ces sites ont une
influence toxiques et délétère sur les
femmes qu'il faut mettre fin à leurs
nuisances et si nous discutons de la
meilleure façon d'y arriver
nous trouverons c'est un problème de
rédaction logistique comme on dit nous
rêvent d'être peut-être attendu
évidemment attention rien écouté par
exemple écouter par exemple bruno
retailleau à quel patron des sénateurs
les républicains et qui a très mal pris
le fait d'être accusée en fait de céder
au lobby catho c'est ce que vous l'avez
dit il répond alors on écoute tu stupide
je lui réponds une chose quand la gauche
est en situation d'échec
elle nous ressort ses vieilles
caricature ces vieilles lunes la loi
veil n'est pas remise en cause c'est un
oui ce qui est un vrai sujet si la
liberté d'expression ce qui est un vrai
sujet pour eux un acte de cette gravité
là et que personne ne remet en cause en
termes je veux dire de liberté de chaque
femme a décidé évidemment est bien c'est
que le gouvernement veuille diviser les
français là où franchement je veux bien
admettre que bruno retailleau à un sujet
sur la discrétion mais il a aussi un
sujet sur une ivg
bruno retailleau était quand même
auparavant un des plus proches adjoints
politique de philippe de villiers
il a été candidat du mpf formation
politique qui n'a jamais caché sa
farouche hostilité à la loi veil et à la
liberté de l'avortement
bruno retailleau d'ailleurs comme
françois fillon n'a voté aucune des lois
de mise en oeuvre de la loi veil et
d'amélioration de la loi veil
il a été saisi le conseil
constitutionnel lorsque nous avons
supprimé la condition de détresse
jusqu'à la voile est prévoyait que les
femmes doivent rapporter la preuve d'une
condition de détresse on se dirait que
femmes savent ce qu'elles font
elles n'ont pas rapporté la preuve de
pourquoi elles font une ivg
c'est leur vie bruno retailleau
faisaient partie des sénateurs qui
avaient saisi conséquence ionel je pense
que bruno retailleau n'a jamais
manifesté dans sa jeunesse pour la
dépénalisation du vg
et qu'on n'a pas été dans les mêmes
mouvements ce sont les années 75 dire
quoi je pense aujourd'hui avec grille
mais alors là je pense qu'ils savent pas
si je pense qu'il fait partie d'un
courant de pensée qui en vend des corps
on pensait le prendre quand c'est fini
historiquement celui de philippe de
villiers non plus d'accord mais ce qu'on
rond sur des questions aussi eu central
dans la dans la pensée d'un individu que
le rapport à libé j'ai d'ailleurs comme
il le dit fais partie de ces gens qui
disent c'est un acte d'une extrême
gravité
la gravité du vg moi je pense que ni vg
n'est pas un acte anodin
non mais qu'il faut cesser de dire aux
femmes qu à chaque fois quel point elles
font quelque chose d'extrêmement grave
ce que je veux dire que c'est si le
sujet c'est la liberté d'expression
probablement trouvé le moyen de se
mettre d'accord mais si le sujet comme
je l'aï entendu à l'assemblée nationale
la semaine dernière parce qu'il y avait
les bruno retailleau de l'assemblée
nationale qui était dans l'hémicycle
petite anecdote il était onze députés
républicains tous ceux qui étaient là
étaient ceux qui n'avaient pas signé qui
n'avaient pas voté la résolution sur les
vg droit fondamental dont il était
bienvenu quand même sur les vg et pas
sur la liberté d'expression et il y
avait pendant toute la journée j'ai
entendu dix hommes nous parler des
femmes et diverger avec une tranquille
assurance une tranquillisants ce qui
n'avait pas l'air de les contrarier
donc c'est bruno retailleau veut bien
nous dire qu'il ne soutient pas ces
sites parce qu'on a à faire il est là c
est ce qu on soutient ou non ces sites
exposés
d'accord vous serrer la main et vous
dites ok au niveau d'un bord quand je
croise du sernam un jeune homme courtois
l'un et l'autre sont hauts on peut
travailler alors qu'on n'y croyait que
chaque mais que chacun dise quelle est
sa position
est-ce qu'on veut ou non réguler ces
sites est ce qu'on veut ou non que les
femmes ne tombent pas entre les mains de
ces faux écoutante qui en réalité ne
sont là que pour les dissuader de
protéger j'entends ce que j'ai entendu à
l'assemblée nationale juste fini
isabelle le callennec député problème
sauf il est très proche de françois
fillon est par ailleurs dont le nom
circule en cas d'alternance intéressant
beaucoup aux affaires sociales à des
choses comme ça c'est intéressant vous
pour les affaires sociales qui nous
anime
dans le débat à l'assemblée que dans le
livret de l'ibg dans les documents qui
sont remis aux femmes qui viennent
pratiquer une ivg
on indique aussi qu'elle est le montant
des allocations familiales auxquelles
les aurez droit s'il renonce et ali vg
et c'est d'essayer de mener leur
grossesse à terme
si c'est ça c'est qu'ils ont dans la
tête c'est sûr qu'on a à paris va se
mettre d'accord sur ces sites
et je me permets juste une chose s'il
n'y a pas d'accord devant vous
repasserez encore une fois par le sénat
une troisième fois côté s'il n'y a pas
d'accord demain il y aura une commission
mixte paritaire et l'assemblée aura le
dernier mot et ensuite tous reprendront
la procédure pas la procédure de navette
voilà c'est un texte c'est une
proposition bois comme les autres et
soumises à la même procédure ne pas
s'asseoir coeur politique et à propos de
l'avortement mais après de l'avortement
sur moi je voulais vous dire on assiste
à une nouvelle passe d'armes entre
marine le pen et sa nièce
vous avez vu marion maréchal qui elle
voudrait revenir sur le remboursement
intégral il limité de lits vgc une passe
d'armes ou bien c'est une répartition
des rôles
je ne sais pas je suis pas experte des
familles le pen ce que je sais c'est que
on peut tout à la fois affirmer affirmé
qu'on ne touchera pas la loi veil et
coupé les moyens de l'axé ali vg et
avoir le même résultat en termes
d'inégalités d'accès de difficultés
d'accès léger que si on touchait à la
loi bâillon et c'est de ça je suis
extrêmement préoccupé pour les mois et
les années à venir dans le discours
arabe d'aujourd'hui et pour l'emmener au
pouvoir pour les cinq mois qui viennent
vous avez encore
travailler sur le sexisme et sur
l'égalité salariale laurence rossignol
merci d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
merci michael bonsoir à tous et à la
semaine prochaine